so one of the things that the
psychedelic philosopher Terence Mckenna
used to say is that the world is made of
words and if you know the words the
world is made of you can make of it
whatever you wish in other words we come
to understand and model reality through
symbolic language so that everything
ultimately is alphabetic everything is a
construct of meaning right this is a
wonderful idea so then it actually
reminds us of the power of language to
not just shape and inform the world but
transform the world in ways that are
unfathomable mean everything is
alphabetic everything is intentionality
and look at the pyramids of Egypt look
at the skyscrapers in the jet engine
these are renderings of the human mind
we live inside of the condensation of
human imagination that's what the
man-made world is and so what does this
tell us well it tells us that better
language can create better realities it
was an amazing article in Nautilus
magazine about how Shakespeare's
inventive use of language actually
stretched the membranes of our minds
like literally what he did in terms of
how to pattern words is an inventive and
elastic use of metaphor literally
changed our biochemistry does
something's through the to the
dopaminergic reward system in our brain
by hinting and queuing and building
expectation and then delivering on that
expectation so that actually we can
measure why his language was so
impactful about human beings why to this
day we still study Shakespeare because
his language literally acts as a kind of
elasticity that stretches and remodeled
and rewires our brain it's open
we can learn from Shakespeare and other
geniuses of the pen and of the word the
power of oratory power rhetoric power
language to instruct author and build
new worlds for ourselves that's what's
about language
you